- [Voiceover] "Which of the
following values is equal
"to the value above?"
And we have the square root of 0.4,
times the square root of 1.25.
Well, one, we could use
an exponent property here,
I guess we could call
it a radical property,
that if I have the square root of a,
times the square root of b,
that's going to be equal to
the square root of a times b.
So, in this case, a would
be 0.4 and b would be 1.25,
so this is going to be the same thing
as the square root of 0.4 times 1.25.
And what is that going to be?
Well, let's see, that's going to be...
Four times 1.25 would be five,
but this is 0.4 times 1.25,
so this is going to be 0.5.
So, this is going to be
the square root of 0.5.
And if I look at the choices over here,
let's see, this is the fourth root of 0.5,
so that's not what it's going to be.
This is the square root of 1.65,
so that's going to be a different value.
This is 0.5, not the square
root of 0.5, this is just 1/2,
but we want to get the square root of 1/2,
so that's not going to be that.
So, this should be the same thing
as the square root of 0.5.
Let's see if that's the case.
So, the square root of 0.5,
that's the same thing as the
square root of 1/2, 0.5 is 1/2.
This is the same thing as the square root
of one over the square root of two.
The square root of one is just one,
so it's one over the square root of two.
And then we could do
what's often called
rationalizing the denominator.
A lot of folks don't like
dividing by an irrational number.
So, we can multiply both the numerator
and the denominator by the same value,
in this case square root of two,
and then we're gonna get
one times square root
of two is square root of
two, and then square root
of two times the square root
of two is going to be two.
So, the square root of 0.5 is indeed equal
to the square root of two over two.
And we are done.